après c'est vrai que les deux mois de
vacances ça coûte bonbon
je vous dis la vérité c'est vrai que moi
je peux rester 2 mois avec les enfants
parce que c'est vrai qu'ici voilà on
arrête le 22 juin mais je pense à tous
les parents organisations
primaire et un autre collège comment tu
fais il y en a un qui retourne à l'école
l'autre qui est
battu de démerdes tu tu tu tu tu tu tu
tu vois comment tu fais tes enfants
tu vois moi ils sont une classe d'écart
j'ai fait des choses bien voilà donc tu
fais ta vie voilà bravo vous faites
comme moi vous visez juste oui mais déjà
je pense qu'il va se mettre tous les
enfants de France ado parce que je pense
qu'il y a pas un enfant
mais tu vois bien que les enfants ça les
sous il y en a pas un qui a envie
d'aller à l'école tout le mois de
juillet tout le mois d'août et là je
pense qu'il y en a pas un qui a envie
d'aller à l'école
de mes enfants justement si tu dis à mes
enfants ils sont en vacances toute
l'année voilà et l'argument des
inégalités il tient pas parce que les
inégalités c'est pas que pendant les
vacances c'est toute l'année donc de
toute façon ça ne sert à rien que ça
allait ça les creuse plus pendant les
vacances c'est comme la réforme des
retraites c'est que tout le monde est
compte sauf que là ça ne sert vraiment à
rien
de Yannick Noah 2022
je me suis pour travail il faut vraiment
qu'on parle
de Yannick Jadot
il faut qu'on se parle là je vais avoir
c’était je t'adore hein chéri mais tu es
la seule pour vous dire que oui
personne ne l'a lu mais oui mais tu te
reposes j'aime bien Yannick Jadot j'ai
rien compris je crois vraiment qu'il y a
des gens qui ont eu son programme
tu es en train de visiter en train de
gâcher ta vie bordel
non mais sans déconner au lieu de
bouffer des culs au Cap d'Agde tu lis le
programme
c'est comme tout le monde dis-lui
vraiment on fait comme tout le monde va
au Cap d'Agde
elle est en train de lire le programme
de Yannick Jadot